de loin l'appareil ressemble à s'y
méprendre à une tondeuse à gazon mais
c'est un géophysicien qui la pilote car
c'est en fait un géoradar en roulant sur
le gazon la machine fait une sorte
d'échographie du sous sol
en gros on va envoyer une impulsion
électromagnétique dans le sol à une
certaine fréquence alors ce qu'elle va
rencontrer une interface type racing
rocher objets ponctuelle ou même
vestiges archéologiques donc le signal
sera renvoyé vers le récepteur peu
l'intérêt de la géophysique c'est ne pas
partir à l'aveuglette ça permet d'avoir
un premier diagnostic du site sans
spécialement à les creuser faire des
fouilles préventives
sachant que tout est une question de
coût et que la géophysique va balayer le
site en un temps réduit
par exemple on va balayer ce site aux
faux comptes et peut-être un ou voir de
jour et contrairement à une fouille
préventive qui durent des mois
cette partie du domaine renferme bien
des surprises en 2012 les archéologues
grâce à des fouilles traditionnelles
avaient découvert une immense salle
seigneuriale elle ne faisait pas 150
mètres carrés comme il le pensait mais
500 aujourd'hui grâce aux géoradar on
soit répondre à d'autres questions
est-ce qu'ils avaient d'autres bâtiments
qui était accolé à ce premier bâtiment
par exemple ici quand on pense grande
salle et bien après on pense à tout ce
qui peut fonctionner avec un bâtiment de
service écuries cuisine ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'on pourra jamais tout fruits
parce que ici sous le parc vous lie et
dernièrement on a des arbres
remarquables un parc a été aménagé au
19e et il est évidemment pas question de
couper ces arbres et enlever cet
aménagement paysager pour pouvoir
fouillé intégralement cette grande salle
chaque année les archéologues fouillent
entre 50 et 70 m² de sous sols mais le
terrain de jeu lui est immense car la
forteresse fait plus de 5 hectares